this all started last year when I
tweeted about this conference that I
really want to go come to PI data and
asked if there was any money to send me
to it and there was and so I'm really
thankful for non focus for giving me
this opportunity because I learned so
much last year and I'm really grateful
to be able to talk this year so what I'm
going to present is the software that my
colleague and I have been working on
called flotilla for open source analysis
of a large-scale RNA seek datasets and
specifically we developed it for a
single cell analysis the slides I just
tweeted them I'm Olga ba on Twitter so
you should be able to find them i highly
recommend following along and even of
cloning the repo and running the code
yourself there the repo is Olga wat / PI
data 2014 bio-data figured a lot of
people repos are called PI data 2014 so
try to make my little different and just
so you know the code is bsd license and
open source so please check it out
alright so what I'm going to talk about
today is overall what our design goals
were with flotilla what we wanted it to
do why single-cell RNA seek is a really
great place to be for data analysis and
I'll show you a few demos of a few
features and then talk about our future
work all right so the basic idea is that
by Ofer mattox the processing of data is
not the problem so the problem is that
the we don't have enough people who are
able to think about the data in
meaningful ways and come up with new
hypotheses and iterate on them there's a
lot of people who are able to generate
the data but there's not enough people
who are can do both here all right so
just to give you a brief history of
sequencing since about two thousand one
to the cost of sequencing per genome has
plummeted faster than Moore's law in
particular now we have cost per genome
about a thousand dollars too thanks to
this high seek x10 and the reason for
this just to show you some biology the
reason for this is that we used to only
be able to sequence literally one strand
at a time
so you had us strand and you read every
single letter on it and you got this
readout for which letter matches and you
see the top line shows only one type of
strand so there's only one read with the
two the second one you see that halfway
through there's two options and that's
because that's the maternal paternal
versions of that sequence of DNA in that
particular person so this is a very very
low throughput you can only look at one
at a time now using the alumina high
seek machines we can we can shatter the
genome and read many different sequences
at once and they have a great new
product hi seek x 10 which is for great
for a genomic sequencing as well alright
there's a lot of pipelines to take this
huge amount of data and get gene
expression values or like what genes are
being expressed and so or what mutations
are around in a particular person or a
particular sample but there's not that
but it's really difficult to get so okay
fine I have these genes but what does
that mean biologically what does that
mean in terms of what is happening in
the cell what does that me for my
biological question so what we wanted to
create was a platform for data-driven
conversations about biology so we want
to promote interactive data exploration
so unlike the previous presentation I
won't have any fancy shiny JavaScript
plots I just have static pngs but we
would like to go into that direction we
also want to increase the decrease of
time for um iterating over hypotheses so
hence the widgets helped a lot we want
so I work with a lot of biologists and
we want them to do the biology so what's
great is that now what I with Litella I
can give them the code I can given the
data and say here here's what you can
look at and they're able to explore on
their own genes that they are that they
care about and assistance I think we
care about using the ipython notebook we
can promote reproducibility it's still
kind of up to the it's not complete
David of Providence but we would really
like to get to complete reproducibility
of datasets
and what's great about this is that now
when I meet with someone I show them a
result I can say okay well here's here's
result I say oh well what if you did
that only on this subset of genes or I
only looked at these samples and now in
meetings I can live code and show them
the result and that has been really
really great and really accelerated our
discovery process now how to get
flotilla so we have a few different ways
so we have a docker instance on our
documentation you can see how to run it
if you already have docker installed
this is the easiest way most
reproducible you don't have to install
any of the dependencies don't have to
worry about anything you can also
install directly from pipe I just push
release like an hour ago so you can
check it out you'll need the latest
release to follow along with this
presentation and also on github we'd
love for you to contribute with your
awesome features all right um I really
like this octo cat all right so why what
is single cell Arnie seek what does this
even mean so you finally heard of genome
sequencing you may not have heard of
transcriptome sequencing so the
transcriptome is what genes are
currently being expressed in the cell so
the genes that are being used in your
skin cells are different from your heart
cells are different from someone else's
skin cells this is a very specific
signature of what genes are being used
and the transcriptome is specifically
the RNA molecules that exist in the cell
so DNA is a very stable good blueprint
and book to read from but it's not that
portable within the cell so you copy the
DNA to RNA molecules and then these can
be used to travel as messengers of
information throughout the cell now why
single-cell RNA seek so this is one
single cell you may wonder why we care
about this one just one of them at a
time and the reason is that these are
pretty cool there this is not it's just
as smooth so there's a lot of things
going on it's kind of hairy there's a
lot of genes being expressed that are
different from other cells and they're
all unique so what's really what I think
is really fascinating is that if you
take a pooled sample you have some value
for gene expression so for example what
is the average eye color of people who
live in New York City you get a value
right you don't get the distribution of
what are
color is in New York City and how that
compares to eichler's and other cities
like Atlanta or Tokyo it's you only get
one value so from single-cell rna-seq
get to see this whole distribution of
our gene expression across populations
all right now how does this actually
work a few years ago this company called
fluid I'm created a single-cell
microfluidic chip that allows you to
sort individual cells so that's what one
of these little chips is and if you're
curious about how it works you have a
suspension of cells in liquid you have
to have a pretty high density so about
two and fifty thousand cells per
milliliter and then you shove them
through this market for the fluidic chip
and they stochastically sort into these
cells and there's 96 cells so you have
to have a lot higher density than as
cells that you get in and you don't get
a hundred percent capture as and you
don't always get 96 cells every time it
kind of depends on your sticky your cell
stickiness so if your cells are really
hairy and have a lot of things sticking
out of them like neurons they can be a
lot harder but a lot of blood cells are
easier all right so on to the
demonstration if you're following along
I'm going to use this data set from
paper published last year on single cell
data set single cell immune cells in
mice so what they did is that they took
bone marrow-derived immune cells so bone
marrow are the B cells and the of the
immune cells the T cells or once a ride
from the thymus so be use for bone and
they subjected them to an immune insult
which is lipopolysaccharide which is
does I don't even know what it does this
is not my field I don't study immune
immunology but it does some kind it
simulates an immune insult such as if
you have an infection or some other
inflammation they have 18 cells so
that's really totally small in the world
of single-cell at this point they these
the same authors in the same group
publish a paper this year with almost
2,000 cells so this is much smaller than
but a nice dataset for this demo and as
a side note I have cleaned up this data
and reproduced all the figures from
their paper in a recent blog post so I
would encourage you to check it out if
you're curious about how this data was
actually created all right so the so
let's get started so the data is
saved to your home directory / flotilla
projects and then name the name of the
data package alright so we've downloaded
a bunch of information we get some
process for progress we got a few error
messages just saying that I didn't
provide any colors and that we didn't
remove any samples that had that had too
few mapped reads meaning that they
weren't sequence deeply enough to really
trust them all right if you in case
you're curious all the study object is
just a wrapper for holding data frames
together so study metadata that metadata
object has the attribute data which is a
pandas dataframe we tried for a long
time to subclass the pandas dataframe
and learn that that is the wrong way to
do things even the pandas developers say
that you should just make a new object
that has a data frame attribute it
becomes a lot easier to work with
there's a lot of it's a very powerful
tool there's a lot of things going under
the hood so I'd recommend just to let it
do its own work and then you do euro
separately so metadata as you can
imagine it says what is the phenotype of
these different cells I've already
failed to filter them for mature and
immature bone marrow-derived dendritic
cells and whether or not this table is a
pooled sample so instead of a single
cell that's about 10,000 cells and the
and whether it's out there or not then
the expression data so our data classes
follow the psyche it learn standard of
the samples are the feature name or the
samples are the row names and the
features are the column names because we
use make heavy use of secular so you
want to stay consistent with that and
what's nice is that most of the heavy
lifting in our package is done in this
base data object and that has all kinds
of great functionality like
dimensionality reduction so if you make
a new object that if you make a new data
type you'll already that inherit from
base data it will already have a
classifier all I have a dimensionality
reduction already be able to standardize
itself there's a lot of great
functionality already been built in so
why we're building this we realize that
we don't just have a Model View
controller as
in many as in other Repole or other
design systems we also have this back in
computer so we wanted to build in make
sure that we nicely build in our compute
back-end and our viewer we would
certainly like to use a more JavaScript
interface but for now we have this pngs
and what's nice is that with this
compute class we have we can really
easily create new new decomposition
algorithms for example this data frame
reducer base abstracts out are the
second learn and what what things we we
specifically like to do with it and then
you can create this new object with very
little code which is really nice all
right so let's get to the demo so
questions that we're going to ask are
doing pca on different data types so so
with this function i can now get the pca
output from this data if you've used i
could learn in the past you may know
that getting the information out is
quite easy it's very nicely designed but
getting it plotted in the way that you
want it can be pretty tricky so we've
now we should with a single command
we're able to do this so now let's we
can try doing this on different data
types so the splicing data is not quite
as clean you'll see that there's these
really bizarre crazy ideas about where
this thing is located in the genome so
let's go back to expression data and I
should point out that the feature subset
we're using that's called variant is our
default default feature subset because
it squishes down the number of genes
you're looking at at a time what it is
is that the variance of these genes is
at least two standard deviations away
from the average variance of all genes
all right so let's so we're back to gene
expression let's look at just the
samples that are not pooled just the
single cells
alright so this so now these orange ones
are from the paper they found these to
be more mature and let's look at what
happens if we do this feature wise so
now what this transpose is the matrix
every dot in here is now a feature it's
a gene and the loadings are now the
samples so let's look at this so this s
12 16 and 13 seem to be on the far right
side of principle component to a
principal component one let's go back
not feature wise and let's look at these
genes that are involved that they that
they curated that are known to be
involved in the lipopolysaccharide
response all right so this is actually
the exact 0 transpose on the the x and y
the x axis is slipped on the negative
but that's just a matter of
initialization and this is basically
exactly the figure from the paper which
is really cool and now what we can do is
so we have these mature samples and
again this would be really great to have
a hover object but have that yet but so
these orange ones I know I apologize if
you can't see it but they are s 12 s 13
and 16 as we saw before so this allows
you to look at your data in multiple
different ways finally a lot of times
we'll ask these violent these pca plots
are can be hard to interpret for the
first time someone seeing them so
they'll see a vector going in some
direction and may not necessarily know
intuitively what that means so let's
look for this gene called a slc 7 a-11
so we have we'll finish up with these
violent plots all right here we go so we
plot all these violins so let's look for
this is alphabetical so let's go to slc
a 11 and that is here so we saw that if
you remember correctly we saw that it
was its direction was greater towards
the green samples and away from the
Oracles so now you can start making
creating mental model of water do these
vectors actually mean and saying that
well if it's in this direction it's more
highly expressed here so this can be
really really great oh and I should
mention that these black dots are the
pool
amples so the pooled samples do not
always exactly represent the single cell
so this just further emphasizes that so
this can be a really great mental bottle
for especially the biologists I work
with because the PCA it can make sense
but in terms of what how what happens to
the jeans and the expression itself can
be um not quite intuitive all right so
let's now oh one other thing I want to
show is that you can so let's turn off
the violins because they take a little
bit long to plot and now you can also
what we often get asked is can you do
this on my favorite gene list so we can
input a specific list this is just a
link to a Dropbox file it looks like a
text file as you would expect so a bunch
of weird gene names and now we can
perform so we can't just use this
straight we have to say that we want
this custom gene list wait a little bit
and now we have our PC a calculated on
this specific gene list ice but I chose
it to be the LPS treatment but you can
choose to be anything you want so in our
lab we often step we study in
neurodegenerative diseases so someone
has a list of their favorite their
favorite autism-related genes or their
favorite a less related genes and
they'll use them all right so now we can
start looking at networks so this from
the default parameter is what you see is
that we're trying to draw a let me go
back actually to these things so what we
do first is we reduce the dimensionality
of the data that's a big part of what we
do first reduce it then using the first
few components calculate covariances
between samples just using those five
those five dimensions use a cutoff on
those covariances to decide whether or
not these samples are related enough
that we want to draw an edge use a
degree cut off for whether or not we
want to plot that sample or not because
if it's a loner we don't want to plot it
and a weight function force for the
edges to push the samples farther apart
and finally a quote-unquote heat map of
the gene of interest so let me show you
that so we have this is graph it's not
too connected so I would like to see how
more samples are
more samples on how they're connected so
let's decrease the cut of the covariance
so this is a plot of overall covariance
and this is where our cutoff is so if we
cut off more to the left and we'll have
more samples and we'll have more
connectivity all right and this is a so
we try to have some informed with plots
about what's what your plot overall
looks like we can increase the number of
components to 11 because 10 is too
little and right now one gene in the
paper that they emphasize is this gene
called irf seven so if you oh so IIF are
seven
alright well let's get that for now so
what is also nice is that again you can
draw the labels if you like and keep
interacting with this plot in many
different ways all right so next we can
do a classification between samples so
this doesn't work at first because I'm
trying to classify on this outlier
variable which doesn't exist miss data
set so let's classify on the maturity of
these cells so as you saw this was going
to be the Orange versus the green before
and let's use the house not the house
keeping the LPS response genes and let's
look at again not the pooled samples
just the single cells alright so this is
going to calculate this and now this is
plotting just the top 23 features and
put doing pca on just those top 23
features of the LPS response that
discriminated between these two
categories and what's what's interesting
is that we come up with actually a few
different genes than what they came up
with in the paper so we can look at some
more new biology here all right so as of
now moving on to a class or key map as
of seaborne or point five point oh I
helped create the cluster heat map in ms
package and now you can easily create
classic heat maps using SNS cluster
seaborne the cluster map and what's nice
is that you can because it's really not
trivial to do in Python in our matlab
there's great libraries for it but as a
Python evangelist I felt like it was my
duty to do this so with this cluster map
what you can do is so this is a
clustered heat map of these samples so
the again the rows are the samples and
the columns are the data now we can take
this and get let's look at the LPS
response genes so you see these orange
samples cluster together again alright
and so we and then we can look again and
see what kinds of genes are clustering
together with these these samples and
and their their dendrogram as far away
so they are actually quite different
from the remaining cells and yeah so
this do you see the streak in the middle
here that's the pooled samples so they
are waste more similar to each other
they are to the single cells because
they have this big average of everything
right now oh and we can also play around
with different metrics let's try since
we're in Manhattan let's try the
Manhattan city lock distance and we can
also use different linkage methods such
as Word or complete don't you single so
it's not a good one and let's also again
do not the pool samples so again this
takes a little bit to compute so the
pool samples are still up here it's the
weight and it's still calculating from
that's black dot so let's wait a little
bit and again alright cool so now we can
see which gene clusters are actually
contributing here all right next this
last one I like to show you is this
interactive correlation so what you can
do is calculate correlations between
samples or between features so again
this is so this is a little bit more
subtle than the previous one what I want
to emphasize is that if you change for
example the feature subset of this what
you're saying is that now I only care
about the correlations between these
features on this between these samples
on this feature subset so it's a little
subtle there and against you see how
these pool chambers are way more similar
and how these s 16 s 13 and 12 I'll keep
clustering together so this isn't many
different ways of viewing the same thing
that these three samples are really
different and this allows you to explore
your data and find different ways of
showing of proving the same point
alright let's also try F let's try
feature wise they make this may take a
little bit of time to calculate this but
it's a it's pretty exciting so this this
feature i literally release this morning
for a flotilla and it's been really
exciting to be able to work with it um
right I think I'm almost out of time so
let me just end with this so I would
love to see many of you contributed
flotilla i see this i see flotilla as a
gateway drug oh cool so this is the
correlation between all genes all
lipopolysaccharide response genes in our
data set
and again and you can always save this
figure as some file that you like
alright so I would love to see you
contribute to flotilla I personally see
it as a gateway drug for biologists into
coding because with as you saw within a
few commands you can do really powerful
things and but research is not one size
fits all there's no way we could all
ever possibly do every can come up with
every possible analysis that someone
wants to do that's why we've kept the
code the underlying code and the
underlying data frame always around so
you can always do whatever analysis
you'd like to do and as you notice that
they all the data needs to be is in the
secular and format of features by
samples it's just a data matrix so any
non biological data is also welcomed all
right and I would like to thank the rest
of the lab ajeno especially my boss my
closely who pioneered the work of the
interactive widgets and presented this
st. similar work at a biological data
science talk Yan song who's right here
so she performed all the scary wet lab
experiments with cells and stuff and she
before we used Travis CI there was Yancy
I who would come up to me and say okay
this is broken now I'd be like yeah
probably i'll try to fix that and the
rest of our single cell team well i also
like to think is uh thank funding from
nome focus i'm a john hunter technology
fellow and my graduate fellowship and
UCSD bar connects distance bio